je ne sais même pas quelle langue j'ai fait cet
arménien salut les enfants
euh c'est l'astronaute Mark Watney nous sommes
environ six heures avant notre lancement ici
sur l'Hermès et les
bonnes gens de la NASA m'ont demandé de vous présenter
certains des  nos coéquipiers ici, ce que je suis
heureux de faire, alors bonjour les terriens,
marquez Watney ici, je suis votre guide personnel
pour cette visite de l'Hermès, c'est le pilote
Rick Martinez qui fait les vérifications avant le vol
, comme vous pouvez le voir, il utilise
des mathématiques assez sophistiquées pour  emmenez-nous sur
Mars,
il a assez de doigts là-bas Rick ne fait que
parcourir mon carnet de chèques salut, je suis le
commandant Melissa Lewis dr.  Chris Beck
, chirurgien de l'air, je m'appelle Alex Logan, je
suis un astronaute allemand, je suis Beth Johanssen,
l'expert en informatique, c'est tout.
les
téléspectateurs qu'est-ce qui mijote de quelque chose de
moelleux et vous entendez des
saucisses Vogel euh Sherman pense que c'est génial
bonjour commandant grande année à venir peut-être pourriez-
vous nous dire ce qui vous a inspiré à
tout prendre sur sûr Laura Clark christa
mcauliffe
et bien sûr eileen collins et vous êtes
Je n'obtiendrai pas une meilleure réponse que ça
sérieusement bien que Rick, comment pouvons-nous
y arriver, vous pointez essentiellement l'oiseau
dans cette direction, vous attendez 150 jours et
36 millions de kilomètres plus tard, nous devrions être sur
Mars, attendez non, c'est Uranus d'
accord, c'est Mars d'accord, vous savez don
ne crois pas un mot ils disent que tu es l'un
des
bons  partir  e pour Mars euh j'espère que
vous avez apprécié votre visite de l'Hermès et
voyez quel équipage stellaire nous avons dire
au revoir équipage mon équipage tout le monde est un
comédien d'accord nous voulons dire
au revoir nous voulons souhaiter à tout le monde ici
sur terre une année incroyable pendant que nous '
je suis parti, allons-y Cubs en fait, que diriez-vous de ne pas gagner ce titre mondial jusqu'à ce que je sois de retour sur terre ouais
ça ne devrait pas être un problème
taisez-vous Martinez est un fan des Yankees de toute
façon que diriez-vous de passer une année merveilleuse, je me
souviens juste de quoi  nous faisons là-haut nous faisons
pour tout le monde ici sur terre cela va
être un voyage incroyable pour
nous tous nous sommes tous dans le même
bateau maman papa t'aime tu vas me manquer et la première
chose que nous ferons à notre retour est  allez chez
Geno pour un plat profond d'accord
Watney je suis